whoa whoa we're heading it's a skyzone
because they have glow Knights so
basically we're gonna be glowing and
jumping on trampolines and we're late
and it's my fault I'm sorry Matt true hi
video where'd you get is he in the car
oh gosh I'm in trouble
oh yeah guys I'm so exciting because
right now we're at sky Zone you guys
have seen us do all kinds of fun
trampoline videos but today this is
something extremely special sky Zone
Japan sky Zone glow I'm dressed very
nicely in my finest meal attire with my
finest Leone friend decides and invited
us out they have a Friday and Saturday
it's basically like a game over you I
really just want to hurry up so that we
can jump please he's like shut your
mouth there me turning the lights off in
like a couple minutes okay let's go so
the lights are about to turn off I gotta
hit the like button
okay let's go jump okay let's rock the
party whose birthdays next October set
huh okay we'll have you ever say yeah I
don't think we've been here all my c-32
messes Cody I got a fun he's gonna be
helping us film today and it's his
birthday so clearly this is a birthday
party for Cody he just didn't know it
and we didn't know
[Music]
that's her a little break we're gonna go
jump some more we're gonna try to keep a
rock climbing wall I tried it before and
I wasn't doing a very good job uh I
think I ate too much pizza but I'll try
that let's see his muscle yeah we don't
we're not feeling
[Music]
long drive I see alright time to home I
am completely exhausted we had so much
fun here the sky Zone glow by far is
just I'm speechless like it's so much
cooler than just normal trampoline park
time normal trampoline is cool too but
they have this on Fridays and Saturdays
this guy's own so check with your local
sky zone's to see if they are
participating in this and if they are
you guys have to go because it was the
best time ever I'm gonna go home and go
to bed we'll see you later Jamie what's
up guys today we're checking out the NES
classic edition this comes out November
11th so huge thinking intended for
sending news early to check out I'm
super excited even just yesterday my
sister was asking if I had a Super
Nintendo or anything here to play some
classic games